[Music]
the bewilder bees are huge
gigantic title class dragons that first
appeared in the movie how to train a
dragon part 2.
they possess the ability to breathe ice
blast which can freeze on impact
and can also be used to create humongous
icy crystal shelters for their dragon
followers
according to the world of dragon's book
their size
is about 520 feet long with a wingspan
of 150 feet and a weight of 200 000
pounds that is around 90 tons more or
less
they have webbing connected coral-like
scales or light spikes that protrude
from the back
of their necks just like godzilla and as
for their teeth
they are relatively small compared to
body ratio
and they also have tail fins which help
them to propel through the water
as we have seen in the movie there are
two types of alpha male bewildered
wildebeest
the white dragon that is valka's
bewildered beast which is snowy white
with charcoal highlighted tips and his
eye color is whitish blue
on the other end we have the black
dragon aka dre ghost bewilder bees
whose physical appearance is dark muddy
gray
with red highlighted tips and his eyes
is reddish in color
let me say just one thing the bewildered
beast had the opposite personality of
the red death
in which he is more subtle and doesn't
rule by fear
but with an alpha call now let's look
into their personalities
the vulca's bewildered bees this one is
very noble
and was diligent and patient enough to
create a fine kingdom
on its own and to provide a heavenly
sanctuary to local dragons
at some point in the past this
bewildered bees came across vulka
it is unclear however whether their
first encounter was before the creation
of the nest
or if walker met the dragon before the
nest was created and
it means that she could have contributed
to assisting the great dragon in
creating the
fine kingdom then we have drago's
bewilder bees
this one is always filled with endless
pain grief desperation
and mostly abysmal rage to everything
including his miserable fate
this anger that caused him to target
everything may go towards the innocent
happier beings especially other members
of his own race
that may cause him further envy loathing
and sorrow
despite being enslaved against his will
the bewildered beast seems to seek
drago's approval
and before leaving for burke the
bewilder beast calls all dragon to him
and once the dragons gather above him he
looks at drago as
if drago is his sole master the next is
their origin
or location valka's bewildered beast
comes from valka's mountain situated in
the north eastern part
of the how to train your dragon map
walker's mountain
is a prime example of nature's
architecture and the mighty bewildered
beast's
ingenuity the mountain is comprised
solely of hexagon and polygon basal
formations these formations are ancient
refinements of pyroclastic eruption
where a basin of lava was able to cool
down slowly
forming the iconic rock pillars because
the mountain sits on a volcanic region
the area is still geologically active
resulting in a great number of hot
springs
the thermal activity paired with the ice
roof creates an unusually
warm climate compared to the surrounding
area
draco's bewildered beast comes from the
northern alliance
drago was designed to look as racially
ambiguous as possible and from a land
far away from the vikings of burke
when he was a boy and lost his family
draco vowed to rise above dragons
thus he set himself to conquer the world
by using dragons
during his earliest conquest he found a
wildebeest hatchling
and raised it with cruelty he then
formed the northern alliance composed of
dragon trappers from numerous nations
such as the slavic the sami inuit and
asiatic clans and tribes
along with thousands of enslaved dragons
he also managed
to build many traps weapons and armor
made for his enslaved dragons themselves
so now that we have the background
information about these two dragons and
their owners
let's see how the battle panned out of
course we all know that draco's
bewildered beasts won the duel
and killed the other alpha dragon but
how did it manage to do so
anyway the battle happened when the
alpha dragon burst out from the fortress
in defense of the other dragons
and at the same time the other
challenger surfaced from the water
they were both equal in size and in the
beginning they were equal in strength as
well
the battle was similar to how rams and
stags fought by ramming against each
other
with their heads or antlers but given
the cruelty in which
the other one was raised and that it
kept on traveling and fighting battles
it possessed more stamina which made the
slightest difference
enabling it to cease an opportunity to
topple down the white beast
and stuff it with its two sharpened
tusks
and that's it that's the comparison of
the two bewilder beast
hope you enjoyed it it was an icy blast
do comment down there and hit that
subscribe button for more dragons and
monster videos